[موسيقى]
اذا هو اليوم الكبير بالنسبه للمنتخب
السعودي بالنسبه لمشجعي الاخضر السعودي
وايضا بالنسبه لمشجعين المنتخب التونسي
اليوم نبدا مباراه السعوديه والارجنتين ثم
ننتقل الى مباراه تونس والدنمارك
ومباراتين صراحه يعني بغايه الصعوبه على
المنتخبين خلينا نبدا المنتخب السعودي
لانه مباراته ابكر شوي من المنتخب التونسي
ونحكي بالتفصيل عن الامور اللي ممكن
يتجنبها المنتخب السعودي لحتى تساعده انه
يطلع بالنتيجه ايجابيه امام الارجنتين
خلينا متفقين انه العامل المعنوي هو
العامل الرئيسي والاهم بالنسبه للاعبي
المنتخب السعودي ما تدخل على المباراه
خايب اليوم عندك مباراه امام منتخب كبير
بلاشك اي منتخب راح يلعب امام المنتخب
الارجنتيني راح يكون خايف بلا شك ولكن
المنتخب السعودي بخبرته الطويله بكاس
العالم بلاعبي المميزين جدا اللي عنده
الخبره كبيره بالمنتديات لازم يكونوا على
الموعد يكونوا عارفين كيف يتعاملوا مع هاي
المباراه ما اراهن عليه بالنسبه للمنتخب
السعودي معنويا في هذه المباراه هو وجود
مدرب بقيمه ايرفي رونار رينار الخبير جدا
رينار صاحب الشخصيه القويه رينار صاحب
العقليه العنيده اللي ما بيرضى انه يدخل
على مباراه وهو خائف او متردد او متوتر
لذلك لازم ينتقل هذا الشعور للاعبي
المنتخب السعودي لازم يكونوا هادئين ولازم
يؤمنوا بحظوظهم بهذه المباراه
الان لما انت بتلعب امام لاعبين بقيمه
ميسي وبقيمه بقيه نجوم المنتخب الارجنتيني
لازم تكون بكامل تركيزه يعني بكل اختصار
وبكل امانه يجب على لاعبين منتخب السعودي
انهن يدخل المباراه
بحالي نفسيه ودهنيه ممتازه جدا جدا جدا
طيب تعال نروح على الجانب التكتيكي بهذه
المباراه اهم ما يمكن ان المنتخب السعودي
يعتمد عليه لايقاف الارجنتيني هو الارتداد
العكسي شو يعني الارتداد العكسي يعني مجرد
ما خساره كره مباشره تضغط على حامل الكره
وبسرعه يعني لازم ما تعطي اللاعب
الارجنتيني حامل الكره اكثر من ثانيتين او
ثلاث ثواني بالكثير لحتى يقدر ياخذ قرار
التمرير او قرار التسديد او قرار بناء
الهجمه او بهذا الامر وبهذه الطريقه تقدر
انك توقف منتخب الارجنتين مع حدا ذلك لا
يمكن انه منتخب الارجنتيني يتوقع يعني اذا
بدنا نلعب بدفاع عميق ونترك مساحات في نص
الملعب ونترك الكره للمنتخب الارجنتيني
اعتقد النتيجه
واذا غامرنا وطلعنا ولعبنا ضغط عالي وضغط
متقدم او ضغط حتى متوسطه وفتحنا مساحات
وراء كذلك الامر لانه في فرق سرعات لصالح
منتخب الارجنتين في فريق تفوق جوده او
جوده اكبر بالواحد على واحد وبالتالي
الامور هتكون صعبه لذلك الحل الوحيد هو
عند لاعبي الوسط ولاعبي الهجوم المنتخب
السعودي قبل لاعبين الدفاع لانه بمجرد ما
خسرت الكره لازم راسا تضغط على حامل الكره
وتمنعه انه يمرر كره باريحيه او يطلع
بالكره باريحيه تغلق عليه زواج تمرير
وتكون جاهز دائما لحاله الارتداد العكسي
باتجاه المرمى الارجنتين طيب الحديث الان
عن ميسي
هناك الكثير من الحديث عن طريقه ايقاف
ميسي على الاسلوب لازم يتبع منتخب
السعوديه للايقاف ميسي بكل امانه ميسي
لاعب صعب ايقافه لانه ميسي يمكن ينام كل
المباراه تحسه انه بيتمشى ويطلع لك بلحظه
يعدي من لاعب
لذلك الرقابه اللصقه على ميسي لم تجدي
نفعل اذا مسكت ميسي عندك عشر لاعبين غير
ميسي قادرين يسجل اهداف لذلك عليك انك
تسكر زواج تمرير على ميسي تحرمه من انه
تصلي الكره باريحيه ولما يستلم الكره
يلاقي امامه كثافه عدديه على الجهه اليسرى
للمنتخب السعودي اليمنى للمنتخب
الارجنتيني لذلك على الشهراني او ايا كان
سيلعب على الجهه اليسرى عند المنتخب
السعودي انه يكون صاحي جدا لهاي النقطه
ويكون في مسانده من الجناح ومسانده من نص
الملعب ايضا هل هي مباراه مستحيل على
المنتخب السعودي الى اعتقد انه مستحيل
بصراحه المنتخب السعودي اثبت خلال
المباريات الوديه انه الدفاع قوي لم يتلقى
اهداف كثيره ويجب ان يدخل تضغوطات لان
الضغوطات بهاي مباراه مش على المنتخب
السعودي الضغوطات على المنتخب الارجنتيني
ليخرج بنتيجه ايجابيه وراضي جماهيره مع
بدايه كاس العالم طيب خلينا نروح بسرعه
الى مباراه تونس والدنمارك تونس اعتقد انه
هاي المباراه المفتاحيه بالنسبه لها
بالتاهل الى الدور المقبل اذا اليوم تونس
بتطلع النتيجه ايجابيه امام الدنمارك راح
يكون امامها فرصه كبيره للعبور الى الدوري
المقبل لانه برعي الشخصي استراليا في
متناول ومباراه فرنسا اخسرها ما في مشكله
تتاهل للدور الثاني الدنمارك منتخب صعب
الميراث عنده لاعبين رائعين جدا عنده كوكب
من النجوم القادرين على صناعه الفرص وخلق
الفرس لذلك اعتقد انه على المنتخب التونسي
انه ينتبه شديد الانتباه بمنطقه نص الملعب
وخصوصا لاركسن لانه اريكسون هو اللاعب
المفتاح بالنسبه للدمرك اركسون هو اللاعب
الاهم اللي راح تبني الدنمارك خططتها عليه
اضف الى ذلك ان انتبه الى تسديدات
كرات خطيره جدا شفناها مع توتنهام خطير
جدا بهذه العمليه لازم يكون في انتباه
كبير ولازم يكون في ايضا انتباه للمهاجمين
تبعون الدنمارك بالكرات العرضيه وخصوص
او اي لاعب اخر سيلعب كمهاجم بالنسبه
للمنتخب الدنماركي المفتاح الاخر بالنسبه
للمنتخب الدنمارك على الجهه اليسرى اذا
لاعب لذلك ايضا
على تونس من مركز حراسه المرمى اعتقد انه
مركز حراسه المرمى راح يشكل خطر كبير على
تونس في هذه البطوله اذا لم يعالج انه ما
شفناها في المباريات الوديه لا يطمئن في
مركز حراسه المرمى بقيه المراكز اعتقد
فيها تنوعيه في مزيج من الخبره والشباب
عند المنتخب التونسي اعتقد ان الاعتماد
على حد اساسي حان وقته ويجب ان يكون الان
لانه ممكن يكون عنصر مفاجاه لاي فريق راح
يلعب ضد المنتخب التونسي
[موسيقى]
اذا هذا حديثنا وهذه يعني ربما قراءاتنا
التكتيكيه لهاتين المباراتين بالتوفيق لكل
المنتخبات المشاركه في هذه البطوله
بالتوفيق للسعوديه للارجنتين للدنمارك
لتونس ولغيرهم من المنتخبات التي ستلعب
اليوم عندنا كمان فرنسا استراليا راح نكون
معكم فيها من الملعب والسعوديه والارجنتين
راح نكون معكم فيها في الملعب فانتظرونا